la parole est à madame pascale gruny
pour le groupe l'est républicain pour
deux minutes mais si monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des finances et des comptes
publics
monsieur le ministre la présentation de
votre dernier budget a suscité beaucoup
d'attentes parce que les enjeux pour
notre pays sont cruciaux mais les
attentes ont rapidement laissé place au
doute à l'assemblée nationale vous avez
affirmé monsieur le ministre vouloir
tenir un discours de vérité
quelle est la vérité lorsque la
réalisation des objectifs en matière de
réduction des dépenses publiques ne
correspond pas aux perspectives
annoncées
la rapporteure socialiste du budget à
l'assemblée nationale
dit elle même ne pas savoir où vous
prendrez un quart des économies
annoncées soit 3,45 milliards d'euros où
est le courage monsieur le ministre
quand vous demandez aux collectivités
territoriales déjà confrontés à de
profondes difficultés d'assumer l'échec
de votre gestion
les collectivités ne pourront pas
supporter une nouvelle baisse des
dotations de l'état sans augmenter les
impôts locaux
ce transfert d'impôts du national vers
le local n'est pas acceptable
où est la vérité enfin quand votre
discours plutôt favorable aux
entreprises se voient contredit par vos
actes report de trois mois de la baisse
des charges salariales révision des
plafonds fiscaux explosion des normes
les français en ont assez ils veulent
des actes concrets et du courage
politique
face à l'urgence monsieur le ministre
vous déciderez vous enfin à mettre en
adéquation vos paroles et vos actes je
vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre la parole qu'à
monsieur michel sa famille lit des
finances les comptes publics
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice la discussion
budgétaire vous l'avez dit a commencé à
l'assemblée nationale il ya deux jours
elle se déroulera bien entendu ici aussi
et nous aurons l'occasion de rentrer
point par point dans un débat important
qui est un des grands éléments du débat
démocratique
mais ce budget en réponse à vos
questions je voulais dire 3,4 chose de
super d'abord il est solide et sérieux
et solide sur les hypothèses qui le
fondent déjà l'année dernière vous même
ici dizier disait au gouvernement vous
prévoyez 1% de croissance pour 2015
vous prévoyez 3 8% de déficit pour 2015
ces mensonges et vous n'y arriverez
jamais ça n'est pas réaliste
la réalité elle est que oui cette année
il y aura 1 % de croissance ou un peu
plus et il y aura 3 8% de déficit ou un
peu moins
voilà la réalité des choses quand je
vous dis qu'il faut parler vérité je les
fais l'année dernière je le fais encore
aujourd'hui notre budget pour l'année
prochaine
s'inscrit dans une hypothèse de 1 5% de
croissance et donc un recul du chômage
et de 3 3% de déficit et nous le
tiendrons
la deuxième chose madame la ministre
c'est que ce budget est marqué par la
baisse d'impôts la baisse des impôts les
impôts et les charges des entreprises
nous avions pris un engagement de 9
milliards de diminution d'impôts et de
charges en faveur des entreprises nous
tiendrons exactement cet engagement de 9
milliards nous avions pris un engagement
de baisses d'impôts pour les ménages 2
milliards de baisses d'impôts pour les
ménages à des prochaines 12 millions sur
10 7 millions de foyers fiscaux en
france verront leurs impôts baisser
enfin comme tout budget c'est un budget
qui finança nombre de priorités
madame la sénateure j'attends avec
beaucoup d'impatience le débat ici parce
qu'à chaque fois que nous prévoyons il
faut conclure nous proposons une
économie vous êtes contre et à chaque
fois quand vous demande ce que vous
voulez comme économie quand vous
prévoyez 150 milliards d'économies je
vous dis nous je ne sais pas il faudra
savoir le courage politique
il sera là allez madame bruni
monsieur le ministre nous ne sommes pas
contre la baisse enfin les économies à
faire seulement nous regrettons qu'elle
se fasse toujours sur les mêmes sur nos
communes sur nos départements ça devient
très compliqué parce que derrière
l'impôt c'est sur le citoyen donc et ça
vous ne m'avez pas répondu sur ce sujet
et sur les impôts
oui vous avez beaucoup augmenté en 2013
et 2014
aujourd'hui vous parler de diminution et
c'est encore les classes moyennes qui
vont s'en prendre un maximum
nous ne pouvons plus accepter merci
merci